Denis is with us in Florida welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show Denise hi Dave
thanks for taking my call today sure
what's up
blessed bit panic I think I'm having an
oh crap moment and as you mentioned in
the one of the previous calls here's my
situation I'm panicked about retirement
so much that it's just I'm thinking
about it 24 hours a day I'm married 54
years old
we have 94 thousand dollars in a 401 K
we have a seven month emergency fund
we have no credit card debt that we have
a mortgage with a balance of one hundred
and twenty seven thousand we have two
cars my husband owes six on his I owe
fifteen online and our income for 2019
was seventy thousand gross a realtor so
my income fluctuate I think that's part
of the challenge but I'm just
panic-stricken
and I I don't know what to do I've least
changed some behaviors the past year but
we don't know where to go from where
we're at well let's see by the time you
are 21 years would be 75 right
Yeah right yeah that 94 would have
become between three and four hundred
thousand if you don't add anything to it
as if you're invested in good growth
stock mutual funds that are averaging
what the market's averaging so that's
not that you are going to add something
to it obviously so our goals need to be
of course become debt-free first get
your emergency fund and that's getting
these cars paid off or sold and paid off
or whatever and our emergency fund in
place so that you can start putting 15%
of your income away which is going to
equate to about $12,000 a year so $1,000
a month
going for the next 15 years or 20 years
you're gonna be fine if you do all of
that and during that time you're gonna
eat your house paid off as well so your
goal needs to be that 11 years from
today at 65
you've become debt free with your
emergency fund way back immediately
right now and you started putting 15% of
your income away while you started
paying off your house I want your house
done by the time you're 65 yeah but
what's so right now we've got the two
car payments my husband owes six
thousand on a Toyota truck that only has
30,000 miles so it doesn't make sense to
sell that I'm thinking we pay that off
and then maybe start trying to make
double payments on my car again
low mileage I owe 15,000 on it but if I
could if I could take that money so say
I get that car paid off when you get
that car paid off and you have your
emergency fund you don't have any
payments but a house payment you start
putting 15% of 70,000 away in 401ks and
Roth IRAs
okay so pay pay the cars off and you
need to do that really really fast she's
caught okay so if I get my husband's
paid car paid off then instead of what I
was going to do is take that money and
pay down my mortgage it's clearly to
card debts immediately like super fast
they're killing you yeah they're sucking
you dry when you don't have any car
payment so now you got money to build up
your merchants you fund right quick of
three to six 25,000 well pay off
everything today with my emergency off
the car yes or sell them and I won't
have any then I won't have an emergency
good build your emergency fund back up
with what used to be car payments okay
but you have $21,000 you'll have 4,000
to start with and you're debt-free by
the time you finish this phone call okay
now I'm not panicked anymore feeling a
whole lot better now now quickly build
build your emergency fund back up but
you don't need a $25,000 emergency fund
with a seven seventy thousand dollar
income you need three to six months of
household expenses so you need a fifteen
thousand dollar emergency fund and then
once that's where the extra emergency
fund because my income fluctuates as a
realtor is like you know some years I
mean I might make 38 years I might make
60 you know so I'll just try to arrow
well you're gonna get in the sixty years
because you're gonna have to get with it
you there's no sitting around anymore
you're gonna have to kick it paid off
don't do that then I get the emergency
fund built back up then you start
putting 15% of your income away 15 okay
to house down any more than above 15%
15% of your income goes into retirement
everything above that you start throwing
at the house okay and that's gonna be
about $1,000 a month roughly right and
so you start putting $1,000 a month away
in 401ks and Roth IRAs and above that
don't don't put 2,000 don't panic above
that let's get this house beat down and
as soon as that house is paid off you
jack up everything then you kick it into
gear and you do all of that and make
sure that the current 401k is invested
in good mutual funds and you put it in
there you're gonna have at 70 years old
you probably have six seven hundred
thousand bucks in a paid-for house but
you guys are not you're probably working
past 65 if you want to head to that to
kind of a direction you're gonna be
millionaires at 70 with your current
income if you do this that's the numbers
we're working right here in front of you
so that's about where you're gonna end
up but you're probably working past 65
oh well I plan to and I don't even need
to so it's gonna be fun selling houses
is fun go sell a bunch of them that's
what I would do
pathos cars today